To look over the horizon and wonder what's
there. It's part of what makes us human. Even
before we were fully human. Some 2 million
years ago, our early ancestors, first left
Africa for Asia, long before the age of European
exploration, ancient Polynesians in canoes
spread throughout the vast Pacific
Phoenicians mastered the Mediterranean and
Vikings crossed the Atlantic
500 years ago in 1519 Magellan set forth on
the first successful voyage to circumnavigate
the entire Globe and in the 20th century,
humans reached the planet's highest peaks
and its distant Poles
With the invention of the airplane. A new
era of exploration was launched
And about a generation after Lindbergh flew
the Atlantic, we reached outer space and a
vast new frontier. It was 50 years ago this
summer that Apollo 11 emerged from a ball
of fire, streaking towards the moon with three
men on board, Neil Armstrong, Buzz Aldrin,
and Michael Collins.
Ladies and gentlemen, it is my pleasure to
introduce it as your pleasure to be in his
presence. The command module pilot for the
Apollo 11 mission, Mike Collins.
Good to see you pal, how are you? Alright
Mike, It's really, it's a great pleasure to
have you here.
Thank you, Miles. It's nice to be here at
this magnificent festival.
Miles O’Brien: Yeah, it's a good crowd out
there. You know, I will command every, the
astronauts, uh, on our program today, all
three of them have written books and with
all due respect to the other two astronauts
will be here. Mike wrote the book on writing
books on flying in space. His book carrying
the fire, which is now back out in print.
Is a beautiful, eloquent tribute to space
with great technical detail and a great sense
of, um, what the mission is all about.
So, uh, I recommend you read that and one
of the things you say in your book at the
end, uh, which kind of struck me is a mission
like Apollo 11 is a mission that really never
ends. Here we are 50 years later you're still
talking about it. And, and one of the, it's
a, it's a blessing and a curse in some ways.
You have to answer the same questions over
and over again. So I need to know right up
front, what's your least favorite question
that you get from the likes of me?
What was it really like up there? What was,
what really like up?
So Mike, what was it really like up there?
No, I uh, it's interesting that question like
you've been holding out or something.
Yes.
But having said all that, uh, I know, um,
the three of you each have had a different
approach. And I'm speaking of Neil Armstrong
and Buzz Aldrin. Uh, it, it, there are times
when you prefer not to talk about it and there
are times when you'd like to, um, what's your
feeling 50 years later now that you've had
a chance to put a little time between you
and the mission, how do you feel about reliving
it in some fashion for people like this?
Well, I like to talk about so many different
facets of, you know, what's it like up there?
What is, what specifically, but I, I like
to talk I guess a about Neil Armstrong a bit.
Uh, um, he and Buzz a were remarkable crew
members. They were, they were just wonderful.
Uh, Neil was, um, I don't want to say the
best of the bunch, but he was the best of
the bunch, we were experimental test pilots.
Uh, and he was a foremost among us, uh, because
of his flying experience with the X-15 rocket
ship, which still today holds speed and altitude
records. He was a very intelligent man. He
had wide, uh, breadth of interests, uh, far
beyond a NASA or the space program, centering
on history, probably the history of science.
But, uh, around, uh, we were very fortunate
after the flight of Apollo 11 to have a around
the world trip.
And Neil was our, uh, our, uh, spokesperson,
uh, at, for those occasions. And, um, wherever
he went, he was a man of few words, but he
had chosen him very carefully. He knew the
background of the country we were visiting.
He knew about a lot about their people and
their country. He welcomed, welcomed the audience
to come with him, aboard the spacecraft and
fly with us. And I, I think I did that successfully.
And uh, the thing that amazed me about it
was that, uh, I thought the reaction would
be uh, you, you Americans um, finally went
to the moon. Instead of that, it was we did
it, we humans, we finally got together, we
did something that is wonderful. We can all
embrace it. North, south, east, west, rich,
poor. Everywhere we went, the reaction was
we did it. And I can't think of another achievement
that has brought such unanimity of opinion
about anything that we humans do here on earth.
It's an amazing irony because it was born
out of cold war rivalry and in the end, instead
of it being, we won, it was like we all did
it. And you'd get congratulations from the
Soviet Union even. That is extraordinary.
Yes, I believe it is.
I know you talk about this sort of a daisy
chain of events that have to occur to make
a mission successful. And um, there are any
number of variables, but in, in many cases
what NASA does is, has wood has redundancy
or redundancies for redundancies. But I do
know, I think you picked 11 spots along the
way of Apollo 11 where you were most concerned
and one of them is, um, what we're going to
see a brief clip of right now. Let's roll
the clip and we'll talk about the significance
of this moment.
July 19, Apollo 11 slows down and goes into
orbit around the moon. The bright blue planet
of earth now lives 238,000 miles beyond the
lunar horizon. Astronauts Armstrong and Aldrin,
now in the lunar module, separate from the
command module. Astronaut Collins remains
behind. Preparation for the lunar module descent
to the moon now begins.
So that moment when the lunar module separated
from the command module, Columbia, the lunar
module being the Eagle, and your two crew
mates went off, that was a tense moment, and
those hours when they were on the surface
were a period of time when you really sweated
the details. Tell us a little bit about what
was going through your mind and your concerns.
Actually the, a, their separation from me
in Columbia and their descent to the landing
was not what was really foremost on my mind.
I thought Neil would do a good job. He'd find
a smooth, nice place to put eagle down. And
although he fiddled and diddled a little bit
on some of the terrain he considered to be
rejectable for one reason or another, he still
found a beautiful landing spot with about
30 seconds of fuel remaining and put it down.
Um, this I kind of expected, uh, what worried
me was the return. We, uh, we in NASA enjoyed,
um, machinery that was redundant. Usually
they, we had to have something, uh, not so
in the case of ascent engine, the engine that
would bring, uh, Neil and Buzz from the surface
back up to me coming by 60 miles above them,
um, that, that just had one, one small little
combustion chamber that had to work properly
or you, we had two dead man on the moon and
that was, I think what was foremost on my
mind. I had a long list of things to worry
about, but uh, I think that was number one.
That burn, that moment, pretty key and clearly
the implications of it not working were a
solo trip back to earth by you. And I assume
you thought a little bit about that.
Well, you know, I did think a lot about it
and I'm sure Neil and Buzz both thought a
lot about it. It was definitely not something
we talked about. He, they knew, I knew, uh,
uh, if, uh, if they couldn't get off for some
reason, a, there was nothing I could do about
it. I had no landing gear on Columbia. I could
not go down and rescue them. I either committed
suicide or came home and, uh, and, and of
course I chose to come home in a situation
like that.
I think that’s a good choice.
I felt that it'd be a marked a man for life
really if I'd been in that situation.
What do you mean when you say you'd be a marked
man? What do you think? How do you think it
would have played out? We don't have to go
too far down that road, but I'm curious.
Well, I, I think people would have been sympathetic
to my situation and they would not have been
critical of me, but for the rest of my life
they say, oh, that's that guy. You know, who
left those two people to die on the moon.
Yeah. That, that, that would be tough. That'd
be tough. Let's, uh, let's go rewind the,
uh, the tape just a little bit and go back
to your early days at NASA. Uh, you, uh, Air
Force fighter pilot and test pilot came to
NASA in class number three. You called yourself
the 14, right? Yeah. There were 14 of us.
So it was the, the first, it was the seven
than the nine, and then the 14. Right. So
this is as a ramped up toward, um, Apollo
and, um, a lot of diversity in that shot wouldn’t
you say? What do you, what do you think? A
lot of white male test pilots in that picture,
you might say.
Oh, oh yes. Yeah, no, no, I quite agree. And
then that seems like a, an aberration today
and it, and it is, and in the future should
be an aberration, but, uh, it wasn't really
NASA's fault. It was society's fault. Uh,
NASA, uh, picked graduates of an experimental
test pilot school, there are are only three
of those around. Uh, so the population available
to, uh, to NASA was very limited. Uh, for
example, NASA recently picked, uh, 12 new,
uh, astronaut candidates. Uh, and to narrow
it down to 12, they started with over 18,000
applications. Uh.
So do your homework kids.
So totally different than in my time. NASA
picked graduates of experimental test pilot
schools. At that time, uh, uh, NASA did not
hire a women to be experimental test pilots.
Uh, there were one or two black candidates
around, but you know, in the flood of applications,
they, they kinda got lost in it somehow. So
that's what you ended up with. It was, however,
I defend NASA in saying that they were not
on purpose selecting white males, that was
our society in those years.
So the decision to pick test pilots, I guess
that makes sense. But they could've gone in
other directions, couldn't they?
Yes, of course. And they have gone another
directions and I'm, I'm glad, they should
go in other directions. We were more concerned
with the up and the down getting these new
machines into the air successfully, uh, testing
them, uh, bringing them back down to earth.
And now that we've gone past that stage and
we're into, what are we going to do up there?
What's the science? What's going on? Why do
people want to go, uh, what can they learn?
And that really has got very little to do
with the upping and the downing that so obsesses
the test pilot.
So this I believe is a picture of you and
some of your class doing survival training
because you know, God forbid if there was
what we would call a downrange abort or a
landing in a location that wasn't the ocean
near an aircraft carrier, you might have to
survive for a few days in a place like the
jungle. And I know you had the great opportunity
to um, camp out and eat Iguana. Is that right?
How was it?
Just like chicken.
What was the, was the training, how much of
the training did you think was kind of nutty
and how much of it was worthwhile?
Well, none of it was out and out nutty. Uh,
some of it was, uh, had been given a great
deal of thought in, in the sense of, suppose
this goes wrong or this gadget breaks. And
uh, and that was what we spent a great deal
of our time doing. Failure mode, we called
it, um, but you can take failure modes to
an extreme. You know what If this does, well
then you fix that. But while you're fixing
that, the other thing goes wrong. Well, we
kind of had a real, well, we just can't go
there. We're going to only pick one horrible
thing at a time and not try to bunch them
all up together.
And inevitably the thing that goes wrong is
the thing you didn't think about, right?
That's, yeah. What, what worries you most
about a flight? You hit the nail on the head
it's that thing that you overlooked in your
training. That's what we worried about.
So let's talk about your first mission in
Space Gemini 10. And by the way, do you to
pronounce the Gemini or Gemini? I've heard
it in the old days. We used to say Gemini.
I hear Gemini. What are you going?
No I, Monday, Wednesday and Friday. I do Gemini
and Tuesday Thursday I go Gemini.
Gemini or Gemini, whatever you prefer. And
I, the Great John Young was your, your crewmate
on that one who ultimately flew in Gemini,
Apollo and the Shuttle Program for many years
flew six shuttle missions and amazing career
at NASA. Uh, but your mission on Gemini 10,
you had two spacewalks, you're the first guy
to do that. Uh, and um, as I understand it,
there are, we don't have many pictures of
that spacewalk. Tell us what happened when
you were out there.
Uh, I think you say I lost my camera. Is that
what you're alluding to? Details, details.
This was the best selfies ever, potentially.
And there they are, they're still floating
around maybe, who knows right?
Who knows, no, my, my job was to leave the
Gemini uh, um, John was flying it in formation
below, fairly close to it, maybe 20, 25 feet
away. And I had a little maneuver unit, a
thing called, we call it a gun cause it sort
of looked like a little pistol you squirted
gas out of that and that allowed you to propel
yourself. And so I had to propel myself over
to the Ageana, our target vehicle that had
been up there for months and uh, and from
it, uh, bring back an experiment package and
return it to the Gemini and that eventually
I did. But I had all kinds of things which
I indelicately call maneuvers ass over tea
kettle, uh, at the end of a 50 foot, uh, umbilical
before I was the second time able to get to
where the package was and bring it ok back
into the Gemini. Without a camera!
And the camera, there it all went. That must
have been slightly disappointing. Of course,
having done the space walk probably made that
a little easier to go get through. Let's talk
a little bit about, you know, we know so much
now, 50 years later, how little was known
about what you were going to accomplish. You
had to rely on all kinds of simulations. We
have a picture here of, I believe it's Buzz
and Neil practicing gathering rocks on the
surface of the moon. And I know you spent
a lot of time learning geology that you wish
you didn't have to spend time doing. But I
do know this, uh, the number of simulations
you did were extremely challenging. What do
you are talking after all about 1969 with
key punches, you know, cards going into computers,
trying to run simulators, simulators that
would crash and so forth. When it came, as
you got closer to that July 16th date for
launch, which was set by virtue of what the
lighting conditions were going to be at the
landing site and you had to launch in that
time or wait another month. Did you guys feel
like you were ready?
Um, I, I'm guessing that if you gave a crew
six months, which is what we had, or a year,
which most of them had, or two years, which
some of them had or even longer and later
on years. Um, I suppose that a, irrespective
of that, the crew would say, well, you know,
I had this notebook, I got 89 things checked
off, but I still got 22 to go. The, that you
never, I don't think fully 100% confident
that you know everything about what is going
to happen or what might happen or might not
happen. Uh, so I think, I think most people
would feel like they could use a little extra
time and I'm sure we did also.
Well, it's hard to simulate something that
hasn't happened before. You have to, there's
a lot of guessing that goes along with that.
Right. In the end do you think the training
match pretty well?
The simulators were extremely accurate based
on what we knew ahead of time. Uh, some of
their presentations, what you saw out the
window, we're not good at all. They were very
crude. But in terms of the duplication of
the instrument panels and more important than
that, uh, the software that backed up how
those instruments would record good events,
bad events, questionable events, that aspect
of the simulator training was, was crucial
to us. And, and, uh, hats off to all the engineers
who put the long hours into designing those
things.
So when you think about what you did, the
millions of parts, millions of subsystems,
all from the low bidder that gave you the
Saturn five and the stack which got you to
the moon and back, even if it's highly effective
and efficient and, and works as planned, even
a small percentage that still gives you thousands
of possible failures with that many systems.
Do you still marvel at how well it worked?
I do indeed. Uh, uh, those machines look smooth
and nice on the outside, inside they can,
uh, be kind of a nightmare. I think in the,
uh, command module a design of one switch,
one switch alone, I believe I had 300 of those
switches. Uh, presumably I should know each
and every detail about every one of the 300.
Clearly I did not. But you know, I tried my
best to learn a few of them anyway.
It's good to have Houston at the other end
of the line, isn't it? Occasionally you might
need them. I want to show you this picture
because you know, almost every astronaut who
goes to space has this, um, sense of moving
forward into the, the, the void, but also
looking back at the planet. And you of course
had this opportunity, um, to see that which
is an earthrise. And I'm sure you remember
the first moment you saw that happen. Uh,
I'm curious to what extent did you, um, discover
the moon and to what extent did you discover
this planet?
On our way to the moon we didn't look at the
moon. I know that sounds strange, but, uh,
we were worried about the constant sunlight
hitting one side of our spacecraft and making
it boiling and ruining instrumentation inside,
the other side would be minus 400 and some
degrees and everything would freeze. So the
solution to that was to turn sideways to the
sun and rotate slowly like chicken on the
barbecue spit, uh, a, in that position we
couldn't see the moon until he got very close
to it. We rolled out then and looked at it.
Oh my God, it was awesome. It was totally
different from that little silver sliver that
you see at night, uh, from Earth. Uh, it filled
our whole window, a big window too, fairly
big filled a whole window, uh, very three-dimensional.
It bulges, its belly bulges out toward us.
Uh, the sun was behind it and it cascaded
all around the rim with this golden glow,
which illuminated the oceans, the flat part,
the marea and also the hilly, the craggy part,
the, uh, big and small craters. And, uh, it
was an awesome spectacle. Uh, and wasn't a
friendly one. It didn't say go away, but it
didn't say come in either.
The moon did not beckon, it didn’t beckon.
But having said all that, having said all
that, the moon was nothing compared to the
earth. Earth was it. It was the, the centerpiece.
It was all, there was a, we had an emotional,
I suppose a rope attaching us to planet earth
for whatever reason. It was what we wanted
to look at. I mean, tiny little thing. You
could make it go away by holding your thumb
out at arm's length. But if you put your hand
down, Woop.
There it was again, it wanted to be looked
at. It uh, tiny is I say the blue and white
colors primarily, the blue of our oceans,
the white of the clouds, little streaks of,
um, of, uh, kind of a reddish tan, things
that we call continents. Uh, very shiny, very
bright, very beautiful. And uh, and yet strange
though it may seem the overriding quality,
well, beauty, I guess I would say, but lurking
right behind beauty was a sense of, it's a
fragile little thing out there. The fragility
of the earth. It was a response that I never
would have suspected. I mean, I know it's
made out of rocks mostly, but it seemed very
fragile. And the more you examine earth, our
planet, the more you discover that fragile
is not a bad word. It is fragile, it's fragile
in thousands of different ways, uh, most of
which are not too good. Sometimes we humans
don't seem like we really deserve to live
on this nice little thing you see from a quarter
of a million miles out.
I want to pick up on that theme a little bit
later in our program when we bring out the
rest of our panel, but I'm, I'm curious, um,
about your thoughts on the space program.
I know, uh, when you, you said that you, you
made the decision Apollo 11 would be your
last space flight it wasn't like you were
hurrying back to the moon, but even in those
days you were like, let's go to Mars. Uh,
and you've, you've been very consistent about
that over the years. Do you feel that that
is still something that should be a, a national
priority or for that matter, a global priority
to put human beings on Mars? And if so, why?
Well, when I came back from Apollo 11, I used
to joke that NASA sent me to the wrong place,
uh, that NASA ought to be renamed the National
Aeronautics and Mars Administration. I even
wrote a book one time 20 some years ago, mission
to Mars. Uh, so I'm, well, what I'm about
to say is a very one sided, uh, right now
the administration is backing a return to
the moon, um, as a, as a way point, a jumping
off point for planet Mars. Uh, and, and that
has a lot of merit. My friend Neil Armstrong,
who was a lot better engineer than I thought
that there were gaps in our knowledge when
we prepare to go to Mars it would be useful
maybe to stop off at the moon and learn a
few things, pick up some of the knowledge
that we didn't have and then go. Uh, however,
I, I disagree with all the experts. I say
that, uh, I believe in the John F. Kennedy
express, if I could call it that, Mars direct.
If we want to go, let's do it. Let's put our
resources into it. Let's pick a way of getting
there. Let's get a schedule. Let's get the
funding. Let's get the timing and so and let's,
let's go to Mars.
Thank you.
So you, I've, you're, you're sort of the,
I would call you the poet laureate of the
Apollo astronauts. You, you have, you're a
very eloquent writer and, and you speak, um,
uh, with great, uh, authority of course on
the technical detail, but you also can capture
what goes on in the right side of the brain.
There is an expression, uh, of course, NASA
has an acronym for everything. And, uh, when
it comes time for a spacecraft to go from
Earth to moon, in other words, fire the rocket
and escape the clutches of Earth's gravity.
They call it trans lunar injection. T L I
kind of a bore, right? TLI.
How do you pronounce that?
So, so he, Mike, I know I want to share a
clip with people because you are the Capcom,
which is the astronauts who speaks to the,
the crew in space for Apollo eight, which
was the first crew in history to have a TLI
command. In other words, to leave the clutches
of Earth’s gravity and go toward the moon
and be pulled in by Earth's gravity. It's
a momentous moment. Let's listen to how this
transpired in mission control for a moment.
If we could.
Apollo eight, Houston.
Go ahead Houston.
Apollo eight you are go for TLI, over.
Roger Houston, we are go for TLI.
TLI, trans-lunar insertion. This was Borman,
Lovell and Anders were ready for the maneuver
that would send them to the moon.
That was a moment in history. And you said,
go for TLI.
Is that all I said? I mean I thought, uh,
I thought the president should be sitting
next to me. The pope would, uh, send a message,
uh, Frank Sinatra would dedicate a song and
instead of that I've got some trans lunar,
whatever you said, a and a TLI. And I'm ah,
but I knew, I knew down inside that, um, that,
that frank Borman would rise to the occasion.
So I was forced by the authorities to say,
Apollo 11 you’re go for TLI. He says, Roger
Houston. That's it. That's all he said.
You know, people watching at home might miss
that moment. So here we are about 51 years
post that moment. Here's your moment for a
do over. What would you say if you could do
it again?
Uh oh. Well, I would've abide by the NASA
rules, which you can't, you can't say more
than I think eight words in a row and preferably
they're all be monosyllabic. But under those
conditions I would say, Apollo eight, uh,
the moon is yours. Go!
That's a good do over. All right, Mike Collins,
we're going to bring out the rest of our panel.
We're going to move into, um, still history
a little bit, but present day as well. The
shuttle ISS era, uh, let's launch into the
shuttle era first.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1, 0 and liftoff of space shuttle
Atlantis on a mission to build, resupply and
to do research on the International Space
Station.
Houston now controlling, Atlantis now begins
its penultimate journey to shore up the International
Space Station. Atlantis now on the proper
alignment for its eight and a half minute
ride to orbit. Four and a half million pounds
of hardware and humans taking aim on the international
outpost.
All right, let's bring out our additional
panelists. First. Uh, the uh, former commander
of the International Space Station. Uh, the
only astronaut with an astronaut twin, the
man who has done the longest stint in space
for a US astronaut on ISS, Scott Kelly!
Thank you.
Joining him is the only NASA astronaut who
also played in the national football league
and a man who somehow was able to sneak in
his two dogs into his official NASA picture.
To this day, no one knows how he did it. The
coolest astronaut we ever met, Leland Melvin!
So, I should tell you I didn't get the memo
on the NASA haircut today.
Its not too late.
I’ve got some scissors in the back.
Should we do that right now? Why not? Let's
just get it over with. Now here's the person
you all want to talk to afterwards cause she
will get you to space in the near term. She
is the director of astronaut and orbital sales
at Blue Origin, Jeff Bezos’s company that
is working on all kinds of exciting things
in space, sending tourists to space, going
to the moon and maybe some day going to Mars,
please welcome Ariane Cornell.
Ok so Scott, as the is the longest tenured
space traveler, all that time in space. We,
you know, we get glimpses of what it's like
up there and we read your books, which they're
good but it's not Carrying the Fire with all
due respect.
I agree a hundred percent.
I recommend these books but uh, nonetheless,
uh, a lot of people, you know, they, they
want to know what and just kind of the simple
questions like what it's like up there. We
seen pictures of you guys playing with food
and stuff and you know, spinning around and
so forth. What, what you, what's the takeaway?
I know it's difficult to explain to people
that haven't been there, but what do you tell
them?
Well, you know, you, you try to share the
experience with it. I'm fortunate enough to
having got to fly in space four times and
spent over 500 days in space, but I’d trade
all of that for what General Collins got to
do here of course, um, you know, floating
is fun. There's no question about it, it makes
sense.
But it makes just about everything harder
to do with two exceptions and that is moving
things that are heavy and also getting your
body into weird positions if you had to like
fix something or you know, connect the a cable
to the back of the TV. But the best part about
it is it’s really, really challenging. It's
a challenging thing to do, to fly in space
to live and work in space. And the best part
about it is just that. Having something that
you feel passionate about, working hard at
it, doing it as part of a team and then being
successful.
So Leland I, would you agree with what Scott
just said about the idea that a destination
would be more fun than, than being in orbit.
In other words, would you trade it off for
a trip to the moon if you could?
I think I would sign up to Michael's JFK express
to Mars, definitely. Yeah. I think that destination
piece will, will inspire you, will motivate
you. You get the country behind it and you
do it. You just go do it.
Would you guys do that one way trip to Mars?
That was bandied about a few years back.
I'm good, no.
Anybody here? Would anybody do that one way
trip to Mars?
You know what I would do? I would do Miles.
Is, um, I would watch that reality show on
TV.
I'm with you on that one. I'm not sure I want
to go with the people who want to go to Mars
one way. Right? There's maybe something wrong
in their lives I’m just guessing.
You know, there's, there's one thing about
traveling in space. Your best mission I think
is the people that you fly with. It's all
about your crewmates.
It's kind of a family that's built up, isn't
it? Yeah. Mike, over the years, your relationship
with Buzz and Neil, you write in your book
about how your, when you were together, uh,
you, you had so many things to talk about
that were of a technical nature that you often
didn't get below the surface. Over the years
did it develop into a closer friendship or
did you maintain sort of a distance from each
other in a way?
Well geography prevented us being really close
all the time, uh, Neil lived in Ohio, Buzz
was, uh, out in California mostly. I live
in Florida, but, uh, we tried to stay in touch.
Um, and, uh, as I said earlier, I got to know
Neil the best, uh, during our round the world
trip. And I really came to admire the many
facets of the man and I was so glad that he
was picked to be the first on the moon.
Yeah. You know, I was, I was shocked by the
fact that for the most important space flight
ever, they'd only trained together for six
months. And that was just absolutely shocking.
Isn’t that extraordinary? In the shuttle
era that it's unheard of. You would think
at least two years of training, right? Would
be about the norm or a year at anyhow. Right?
Ariane, let's talk about the commercial component
now. You know, the shuttle's gone now eight
years. The shuttle was an amazing machine,
but it was, it was meant to be cheap and easy
access to space. That didn't quite happen.
As a matter of fact, not even close. It was
actually pretty dangerous and expensive. And,
we're in a different era now where we're thinking
about, um, lots of people going to space.
Um, what's The big vision right now is, is
it, is it for people who could afford $200,000
or I've heard Jeff Bezos and, and others,
we won't mention competitors, but others talk
about sending millions of humans into the
cosmos. Is that, is that even a realistic
notion right now?
Yes. So, in fact, our, our vision at Blue
Origin is millions of people ultimately to
be living and working in space. Um, that obviously
is not happening tomorrow. Um, and our, our
motto at Blue Origin is something it's Gradatim
Ferociter, which in Latin means step by step
ferociously, and that's how we're going to
approach it. Um, and our first step at Blue
Origin is a suborbital rocket called New Shepard
named after Alan Shepherd, of course, the
first American in suborbital space. And by
the end of this year, we're going to be putting
tourists on board New Shepherd. People like
you and me, um, are going to be going up in
space. Uh, initially, you know, you're gonna
get three to four minutes of weightlessness,
so maybe not to quite orbiting the earth or
the moon for that matter yet. But our next
plan is New Glenn, a big orbital rocket that’s
set to fly in 2021 that is going to be human
rated. Uh, and ultimately we will be taking
people to, uh, to, uh, space stations, to
the moon, to Mars. No, we're, we're really,
uh, a destination agnostic, if you will. But
ultimately we will be taking many, many people
to the, to space.
So Ariane, when you talk about taking many,
many people or maybe even one day, millions
of people to space, uh, what I think about
is what just happened on Mount Everest and
uh, it can get crowded up there. You should,
should, can anybody go to space? Should everyone
go to space? And I want to get the astronauts
to weigh in on that too. I mean, is there,
should we set a bar or are we reaching, is
will there one day be at a time when it, it'd
be just as simple as getting on a commercial
airliner?
Well, the, the latter is our intent. I mean,
you know, with, with New Shepard, you're going
to be able to fly to space in what we call
a shirtsleeve environment. So literally what
you guys are wearing right now, you could
come fly on New Shepard with, uh, as in terms
of clothing. And the other thing is what we're
trying to open up space for as many people
as possible.
We want the training for it even less than
six months. It's just going to be about a
day and a half. The intent in fact is to make
it so that as many people can go as possible.
So it will be like getting on a commercial
airline. If you think about getting on an
airplane today, you sit there, matter of fact,
maybe you're on your iPhone even and the,
you know, the training video is maybe two
minutes. Um, we, we want, we want this to
be, we're gonna train you and make you feel
comfortable, but we also want to make it to
be uh, simple. And that's, that's important.
All right, astronauts, what do you think can,
Leland why don't you go ahead? I know this
is near and dear to you. You guys think about
this a lot because after all you had to go
through a lot of training to go there and
it's nothing to be taken lightly, at least
as it is now.
You know, I've thought about what my Aha moment
would be in space before I left the planet
and I thought it would be when we install
the Columbus laboratory with a robotic arm
because that was my, my job and my primary
mission objective. That paled in comparison
to when Peggy Whitson, the first female commander
invited us to have a meal in the Russian segment.
She said, you guys bring the rehydrated vegetables,
we'll have the meats, right? She said that.
So we float over with this bag of vegetables.
We get there and it's African American, Asian
American, French, German, Russian, the first
female commander going around the planet every
90 minutes at 17,500 miles per hour. And I
felt like I was at home. We were breaking
bread with people we used to fight against,
the Russians and the Germans. And then when
I looked out the window at Lynchburg, Virginia,
my hometown, and then I'm thinking my parents
would probably have a meatloaf down there,
right?
Five minutes later we're over Paris. Leo Eyharts
is looking down his parents probably having
wine and cheese or something and Yuri’s
looking off at his parents probably eating
Borscht in Moscow. So in this very short period
of time, we are celebrating all of humanity
as we go around the planet. And that perspective
shift that I got was my Aha moment. And so
if more people, if millions of people can
get a chance to go to space and get this perspective
shift that I got and get this connection back
to the planet. I think it will advance our
civilization, it will advance our race, the
human race so significantly. My opinion.
So Mike, if I’d talked to you in, um, after
you got out of quarantine in August of 69,
if I had asked you, can you imagine a day
when that scene he just described happened,
will happen, Russians breaking bread with
Americans, the diversity, the whole component
of the space station. Would you have said
that was likely?
I think it, I think it could very well be.
Uh, I, I, I harked back as I say to, uh, uh,
post Apollo 11, around the world trip. Everyone
saying we did, right? What color were they?
Were they male or female who said, we did
it? Who's this we? It was we, humankind that
got all together, believe it or not. And I
actually agreed on something. We did it. I
think that's a wonderful moment to remember
and to treasure and we can have that I say
world in my window, uh, I transfer that to
you, world in your window. Well what is your
world telling you about these things? You
can have it, you can have a voice in it small,
but you can have a voice in it.
You know, I think there could be a mission
profile for just about anyone. And you know,
the entry point would be the suborbital flight
and I think you can probably fly, you know,
99.9% of the population on that type of mission.
Now you take that a couple of step further,
steps further and then you would have a flight
like a shuttle flight. And that would be for,
you know, someone may be a little bit more,
you know, extreme adventure minded person
and then living in space. It's, you know,
it's a challenging place to live and it is
not for everyone, but it's for potentially
a lot of people. But I think, you know, in
our future we'll have a lot of different opportunities
for that. All of those collectively would
be able to potentially include most of the
population of the planet.
So let's, let's talk about long duration space
travel, which you on this panel have unique
insight into. You uh, went to the space station
for about a year and, uh, this was not just
a, an endurance test. There was a lot of science
associated with this and it helps the, uh,
the science is helped by the fact that you
have an identical twin brother who happens
to be or was an astronaut, uh, Mark Kelly
who's now running for Senate, by the way,
in Arizona. Yeah.
Got a great uh, video.
That's my brother cheering.
I told Scott earlier that he could help him
on the campaign trail because who would know
it was him campaigning twice, twice the campaign
power right there. So let's talk about a year
in space though. There was some science that
was done. What was, what was the point? What
were they trying to get at? What did we not
know that we might have learned by virtue
of you being up there for so long?
So those people that understand science and
you may be a scientist or you just, uh, you
know, are interested in it as a hobby. You
understand that for an experiment to be statistically
significant, you need a very large sample.
So clearly this is a sample of one. There's
only one sample and that is my brother and
I comparing, uh, me and space with my brother
as the control subject on earth. So the stuff
we find from this experiment, which was a
bunch of different things, it's basically
considered anecdotal information. It's interesting.
It's something that you can look at and then,
um, decide that we need to investigate further.
And there were a lot of, um, results that
were surprising, you know, uh, as an example,
my telomeres and the telomeres are the ends
of our, uh, chromosomes. And as we, uh, as
we age, they get shorter and more frayed.
It's basically, basically an indication of
our physical age. And the hypothesis was me
in space, uh, you know, the radiation, challenging
environment, stress or whatever, my telomeres
would get, uh, shorter compared to my brothers
on earth. Well, they actually got better.
Now some people thought that they improve
because of the, you know, the restricted diet
you're on, exercise. Um, you know, a very
controlled schedule maybe. But recently I
found out there were also, uh, some worms
on the space station, that their telomeres
actually improved as well. And the fact that
I never saw them exercising, never once saw
him on the treadmill or lifting weights. And
also the fact that mine went back to normal
pretty soon after I got back means there's
some kind of genetic thing going on that we
don't quite understand. Um, I also had some,
you know, 7% of my, uh, gene expression had
changed, uh, during the course of the year.
So there are some genetic things we need to
look at, uh, further and investigate further,
I think as part of our plan to send people
to Mars someday.
Can I say something?
Yeah.
I, I'm just, uh, you know, Hark back, uh,
just, uh, a few years before that on Gemini,
we were just amazed. We thought we were really
reaching out. We thought we'd reach maybe
the limit. We sent two people up for 14 days.
I don't think you'd unpacked in 14 days.
Probably didn't even use the bathroom.
But if you've taken a look at a Gemini spacecraft,
14 days in a Gemini versus a year on an ISS,
I don't know. I, it might be a, might've been
a harder mission. For those two, that, they
had very little room. But let's go back to
that site one more time because it talks about
your cognition. How is your cognition anyway?
You seem to be doing okay tonight.
Yeah. You know, a lot of people have focused
in on the fact that when I got back, my cognition
declined. I pretty much improved throughout
the mission. And I think that's a function
of, you know, the longer you're in space,
the more comfortable you feel. I never actually
felt normal. I don't think anyone would ever
feel completely normal. You always have the
fluid shift to your head. On the ISS the CO2,
even when it's at its lowest, it's still high.
The CO2 bothered you on that.
Yeah. And you can feel it. Um, I could tell
within, you know, a 10th of a millimeter what
it was and then I could look and see that
I was, I was pretty accurate. So you know,
throughout the mission you're, you're feeling
better. Never perfect. You're doing these
tests over and over so you're getting better
at them. So I think that was why my cognition
got better. And then when I got back, I don't
really think it was a like a cognition deficit
I had. I think it was more of the fact that
I just didn't feel well when I got back from
Earth, back to Earth. And when you don't feel
well, like imagine going to take the SAT if
you had the flu, you probably wouldn't do
well. That's kind of, I think why they saw
a decline that was noticeable when I got back.
It was just a function of how tired I was
and physically did not feel well.
Sure. So let me get this straight. As CO2
rises, you get cranky and you don't feel well.
So you were kind of a lab rat for the future
of climate change in some respects. Huh?
Tell you what, you know, when, like I said,
with CO2 at its lowest, it's 10 times what
it is on earth, on the space station. Sometimes
it's 30 times.
So we're at like 415 parts per million. It's
30, 30 times that? Right? That's just, that's
amazing.
Wow.
Yeah. Well It's 10 times what it is at its
lowest on the, on, on ISS and it is not comfortable.
Huh. And that's just because they want to
save the machines. They could dial it. So
it's a little easier on you but…
Yeah, you know, it's, it's partly resources,
problems. You know, you, you don't want to
use all your spare parts when the, you know,
the supply chain is uh, not reliable. Um,
some times things blow up.
It's hard to get to the home depot. Leland,
you also spent a good deal of your time as
an astronaut in, um, in Washington, but not
a lot of space flights there, but a lot of
engagement with young people. And you, you
headed the, uh, education office for a time.
I'm curious what your thoughts are, having
had that experience of being in space and
then and trying to reach out to young people,
many of whom are in this audience. The value
of space as a way to inspire young people
and teach them about things like climate change
and CO2 for example, or little things like
that or, or what it's like to be in space
or telomeres for that matter. How much value
is there in that?
I think it's extremely valuable because it's
one of those things where I would go into
a classroom and the kids love dinosaurs and
space. And so if you can, if you can genetically
make a dinonaut you'd be golden, right? But
you know, the reason I have my blue flight
suit, I got the memo to wear the jacket, but
lots of times, you know I got something on
Facebook from a mother Kelly out there somewhere
who's bringing her eight year old son here
to see this and the suit for a lot of kids
in communities that I go into would never
imagine even thinking about going to space
and certain zip codes didn't even know what
an astronaut is. But I walk into that neighborhood
with this on and they ask the question, what
is that? Where did you go? Who designed that?
And that starts the, the exploration.
And I think once we, you know, once we have
their interest just a little bit, then you
can start changing the way they think, their
mindset about what they can do with their
lives. And representation, it truly does matter.
Michael, you talked about earlier about how
diverse that pitcher was not, those original
people and how we've changed now in this day
and age of who we're sending to space and
who's representing, you know, the future of,
of humanity. And I think education is one
of the things that you can get a kid inspired.
My mother gave me a chemistry set when I was
probably in middle school and it was age inappropriate,
non OSHA certified. And I created the most
incredible explosion in her living room, burned
a hole in her carpet. And then she had a hand
in my development, you know, but my brain
was activated, I majored in chemistry while
playing football in college because of that
one intervention. So if we can find interventions
using the space station, using Legos on the
space station, going to Mars, and letting
kids see that they can get to Mars. It's this,
that's the way using space as a tool.
Let's talk a little bit more about the commercialization
of space. First of all, the uh, Blue Origin
is just part of a big picture here. You've
flown 11 times now. L et's take a look at
the most recent launch, which was earlier
in first part of May, right? Let's watch it.
So this rocket, this is New Shepard. Uh, the,
the capsule and the booster lift off together
and at about 75 kilometers the capsule separates
from the booster and you go over a hundred
kilometers. So that view there is, that's
the beautiful view you guys are going to be
seeing when you're up in space. The booster
comes back down to land because we reuse the
rocket and then the capsule itself comes down
under three parachutes. And just the last
second, we have a retro thrust system or basically
like an air cushion that gives you a nice
soft landing. We’ve also, you saw in that
film we've done quite a few um, uh, extreme
tests on the vehicle to what we say as we
say, test the corners of the system to make
sure it can work, uh, in emergency situations
or uh, in, in off, what we call off nominal
situations and we're, we're getting very close
to flying people. We're going to be putting
people on top of that rocket at the end of
this year. You want to come flying with me?
Excellent. Yeah. Excellent. We're all in for
that. Excellent.
So when you say soon, uh, I know it's hard
to pin things. Are we talking about a year
or less than a year from now? What are you
thinking?
So we, our aim is to put people on this rocket
by the end of the year. And so, uh, we had
another, uh, as miles mentioned, the last
flight was in May. It was the smoothest to
date. We are, we are really hitting our stride.
Um, but most importantly we are not going
to fly people, uh, until, until the entire
team is ready and we feel, um, that we've,
we've got a handle on the system, but we're
getting close. I, I would jump on that rocket
tomorrow. Uh, if given the opportunity, um,
we, you know, some of the tests that you saw
there, we have an escape motor in the capsule.
We've tested on the ground. We've tested it
at, we'll be called Max Q or the most, um,
aerodynamically, uh, intense moment on the
rocket, performed perfectly. We performed
it up at, um, Max altitude. I mean things
are going very well on the system, so.
So it's not just about flying tourists. However,
I know Jeff Bezos vision is much grander than
that. And he also just within the past month
or so announced his, uh, his lander-
Blue Moon.
Blue Moon, which would go to the moon. Tell
us about Blue Moon and what his goals are
there. Uh, I was at this same NASA meeting
I was at this morning. There was a lot of
talk about Blue Moon as being part of the
architecture of NASA’s renewed interest
in going to the moon sooner because they don't
have a lender. And this project has been going
on for a little while and you guys just don't,
you're kind of secret about your projects
generally. But let's look at what Blue Moon
looks like and why don't you explain what
the potential missions might be for it.
Of course. So what you're seeing here, so
this is Blue Moon, our lunar lander. Uh, the
intent with this, uh, this craft is to take
about 3.6 metric tons to the lunar surface.
And eventually 6.5 metric tons. On the way
to the surface of the moon we can also, uh,
deploy small satellites and some other scientific
craft to, to take data. And then the, uh,
Blue Moon itself will land on top of blue,
uh, of the Blue Moon Lander. We can take,
uh, rovers. We can take other craft and, and
place them onto the lunar surface. So this,
this, uh, our Blue Moon program fits perfectly
into, uh, the administration's plans to land
on the moon by 2024. We've been at it for
the last three years, which is why we can,
we could jump to such, um, uh, an aggressive
timeline. We're, we're ready. And, and one
of the, you know, I was talking about earlier
Gradatim Ferociter, step by step ferociously.
One of the reasons why we're going to be doing
this or we're able to do this is that we've
taught ourselves how to land rockets here
on earth, uh, which has six times as much
gravity is a up on the moon. Um, so we, there
are systems that we've been working on for
a while that's going to enable Blue Moon.
So there, there is a little bit of confusion
about this when you get into this idea of
commercial space because the truth of the
matter is NASA has never built a rocket. There's
always been a contractor in the mix. Uh, and
it's just how the contracts are structured.
NASA in this case might buy a service, get
me to the surface and back. Whereas in the
days when you were, you know, shepherding
through that, uh, that uh, command module
you were in on the factory floor every week
making sure everything was connected in the
right way. It, what are the pros and cons
of that. On the one hand, it sounds like that
would be safer cause you're really paying
attention to how the craft is built. On the
other hand, you have less visibility into
how it is built. What are your thoughts on
it Mike, is it inherently safer to do it the
way you did it back in the 60s?
I don't know about to safety, but I don't
think a dollar bill knows whether it's a federal
dollar bill or a commercial dollar bill. I
don't know how you can say no to the overtures
of Jeff Bezos and uh, and, and some others,
uh, to put part of the, their private funds,
uh, to add those to the, uh, federally appropriated,
uh, Kitty and you can do more with more than
you can with less and I, I welcome aboard.
I think it's wonderful.
What do you guys think? Scott would you have
any hesitation flying on whether it's a, a,
you know, a Blue Origin craft or a SpaceX
craft to the space station or perhaps beyond?
Would you do it?
I would have hesitation flying on anything.
Which is appropriate, right?
It is very risky. Um, uh, you know, as we
get more experience, it becomes less risky.
So, uh, I would want to learn about the rocket,
understand the systems, the redundancy, but
I think, you know, I could, I would probably,
uh, having done that, absolutely fly on a
Blue Origin or SpaceX rocket. I mean they,
I've been to Blue Origin, I'd been to SpaceX.
They, uh, those two companies, both seem very,
very professional, very talented people. But,
um, yeah, I wouldn't just jump on without
understanding it because I want to come back.
I like Earth.
I'm just going to say we're not building this
in a vacuum, but that, that has a different
context. And, you know, we, we are, uh, you
know, as people, we're standing on shoulders
of giants. They’re sitting on this stage
with me. Um, believe it or not, I'm having
a hard time believing it, but, um, it's, we
have, we worked very closely with NASA. We
take a lot of lessons learned from decades
past. Uh, at Blue. We have a really nice mix
of, um, veterans who've been in the industry
for decades.
NASA astronauts.
NASA astronauts. We've got three veteran NASA
astronauts, ah, working at Blue, including
the head of the New Shepard program. Um, so
we, and we also have those that are coming
out of, out of university. So we've got this
really nice balance because we really, really
do believe that this company and these, these
projects are going to be around for a while.
So we, we are building a system that's going
to be the, the workhorse for the American
space industry for decades to come. But the
only way that we can do that is with really
good relationships with NASA and with, uh,
with those that have done it in the past.
Yeah.
Leland, how about you? Any hesitations?
I think the, uh, the rewards outweigh the
risk. When I, when I went to space on the
shuttle, you know, it was the lowest bidder,
right? I got there and I undid my seatbelt
and I floated over to the window and I looked
out and I was looking at the Caribbean ocean
and I needed new definitions of the color
blue to describe what I saw. And that also
fundamentally changed me. And if we can get
more people to share that experience back,
you know, back to the planet, you'll get more
energy around exploring. You'll get more kids
excited, you'll get more people doing things,
working together as one humanity, and that's
how it's worth it to me to take the risk.
Mike, I know when you were orbiting the moon,
uh, you radioed down at one point, or maybe
you were on your way back, but you said something
to the effect, I wish, you know, several hundred
million Americans could have this experience
with me. How do you think that would change
life on earth?
I don't know. I don't think he even, I don't
think you have to go to the moon. I'd go up,
a hundred miles is a nice, uh, orbital. I
mean, you're above all that friction stuff
there and uh, you, you'd be, you got the,
uh, the communist and the capitalist and a,
they're side by side looking out a window.
Hell, they can't even find their own country
much less say that one is better than that
one. Uh, I, I think it would in subtle ways
really change the way political leaders think
about their, their own turf and other people's,
if it, if you can divide turf into, theirs
and ours, uh, how you, how you deal with things
on a unified global basis. I think it would
help.
Yeah. My, my uh, my guy called my Russian
brother from another mother, Mikhail Kornienko,
Misha, my um, guy I spent nearly a year in
space. He would sometimes say on the space
station when we were there, he would say,
you know, if our two countries wanted to solve,
uh, any differences, solve the problems we
have with one another. All we need to do is
put our two presidents in space together for
a year.
Leland, this idea, it's been written about
quite a bit. This idea of, it's called the
overview effect. There is some, something
that changes when people have this ability.
Is that real? What is it about it? Is there
something that really changes the way you
view life when you get back down on terra
firma or is it just a fleeting moment in space
and you're back to your everyday life?
Well, before I went to space, I was driving
down, I was driving from Houston down to Clear
Lake on highway 45 and this, driving my car
and this guy in this big pickup truck with
the big mirrors and the dually cuts me off
and I, I go blep blep. I probably say some
things I probably shouldn't have said. And
then the same thing happened, but this time
I was driving from Clear Lake to Houston after
flying in space. And I just said to myself,
dude, you can't hurt me. I've been to space,
and I do feel like, I mean, Frank White would
a book about this called The Overview Effect.
And it's a cognitive shift that people get
when they see the planet from this vantage
point. I feel like there was something cognitively
that changed in me, especially when I was
breaking bread with Peggy and the rest of
the team over there in the Russian segment.
And it did feel like something, you know,
fundamentally changed. Now. Did you, did you
feel that?
Yeah, of course. Um, you know, and I would
describe it, um, a little bit more. You know,
when you look at the earth, you don't see
any political borders. Uh, when you look at
the earth from space, not like we expect to
see it on a map, you think of earth in terms
of, you know, before you flown in space, you
think of how you view it on map with political
borders. Of course, you know, you could see
those at night, uh, with the lighting in different
countries, but during the daytime you don't,
you see an incredibly beautiful planet. Uh,
you know, because you follow the news that
there are a lot of bad things that go on,
on a daily basis on planet earth. Uh, and
these are problems that are solvable when
you're on the space station, this $100 billion
space nation, probably one of the hardest
things we've ever done.
Uh, if we can do that, you recognize we can,
you know, do other things to help humanity.
The other thing you notice is just how fragile
the atmosphere is. It looks like a thin film
over the surface of the earth. When we're
on the ground, you look up, the sky looks
infinite. When you're in space, I remember
one of my first days in space I was like,
what is that film? And then you realize that
is our atmosphere, just the, where all the
pollutants start going into. You know, there's
some parts of the earth almost always covered
with pollution, parts of Asia. I think, you
know, kids in those countries, if you asked
them what color the sky was, they'd probably
say brown or, or gray. You know, the rainforest
in South America. I noticed a very, very obvious
change between my first flight in 1999 my
last in 2016 you know, fires over certain
parts of the, the continents. You see the
effect of people that have, how people affect
this planet, which is incredibly beautiful
but also incredibly fragile.
I think we talk about fragility of the planet,
but I, and I, I hear what you, both of you
have said about the fragile oasis, but I think
that it's not that the planet is fragile,
its that we are screwing it up and that we're
going to be burped out and the planet will
be resilient and fix itself later. So we're
doing it to the planet and doing it to ourselves.
And it's, uh, its going to be us.
So one of the, really the reason why, uh,
Blue is so focused on these reusable rockets
that you talk about is to, uh, access the
resources of space, but it really is to help
earth. So it's bringing the resources down.
But ultimately part of our grander vision
is how, how do we get heavy industry off the
planet? How do we get these pollutant, uh,
elements and industries off and maybe use
earth just for residential and maybe some
light industry space has a lot of, it might
sound far off, but the moment that we're gonna
hit that, that oh, oh gosh, moment, it's going
to be too late to work on technologies that
are gonna be necessary to get us up there
and get back in and bring resources back and
get some of these, uh, um, again, infrastructure
up into space. Help us here on earth. There
should not be a plan B. We've been to every
single one of the planets and this one by
far is the best. So we got to do what we can
to keep this one happy and healthy.
Yeah. So Mike, uh, I know you've had similar,
uh, it's had a similar effect on you and made
you very concerned about the environment.
Tell us a little bit about how your view of
the earth, that earthrise and being able to
cover up everything you know, with your thumb,
how that changed you as you lived out the
last 50 years.
Not, not, hadn't changed me enough. I haven't
done a particularly good job in the last 50
years of, uh, putting my, uh, my footprints
or uh, my bank account where my money is,
I mean, where my mouth is. Uh, I think we
can, I don't think I'm rare in that. I mean,
we, I think we talk a good game. I'm not sure
we play a good game. Uh, I certainly have
not. I, uh, I, I pursue my own hobbies and
whatnot without really giving consideration
of a sufficient consideration to, uh, the
fragility and, and, um, and, and, and of course,
uh, you're absolutely right about the, is
it really fragile or are we fragile people
living on a rock, not sure that matters. Something
is fragile system is fragile. And, uh, I,
I certainly worry about that. The word fragility
just floats in and out of my head whether
I wanted it or not.
Isn't that what you're writing about right
now though? Tell us a little bit about it.
Um, well I'm, I'm writing a book number five.
It's a series of essays and, uh, one of them
touches on what we're talking about which
is world population. What should the world
population be? Uh, is anyone working on trying
to find an answer to that? I don't think so.
You know, there are organizations, international
organizations, but, uh, the, they right, uh,
learned papers that they pass back and forth
between half a dozen people and, uh, and their,
their, their conclusions don't ever seem to
reach, uh, the politicians. Uh, uh, when we
flew to the moon, the world population was
2 billion. And uh, now it's, uh, I think around
eight. Predictions are, is going to fairly
soon be 10. And is that sensible? Is that
okay? Well, maybe, I don't think so however,
but, but my main point is not whether I think
it's too big, too small or just right, but
that no one is paying the attention to it
that nation should pay. And it's an extraordinarily
difficult, uh, uh, problem because we all
know the diversity of north south one factor
after another. But somehow we have to get
all these, uh, competitive, uh, countries
together to try to at least plan on where
are we going, where, what do we want it to
be next fiscal year, 10 fiscal years, whatever.
I think we should be working the problem and
we're not.
So we face this time of kind of peril and
promise. The promise is a lot of the excitement
that we hear here and how space can help us
in ways, but does space at some point become
frivolous and a waste or will it always be
some means towards solving problems here.
I think the latter, but I've, you know, I'm,
I might be a bit biased on that, but no, I
mean you, you are literally looking into infinity,
right? This image that you're looking here,
the amount of resources that we can, that
we can access and use and enhance, you know,
if we’re looking at a, ultimately a population
cap we’re walking towards stasis, that's
sad. Humanity is supposed to expand, is supposed
to evolve. I mean, how, you know, think about
things just plateauing or even going backwards
that seems, yeah, that just makes me sad.
I think we will continue to look to space
and what it has to offer for our future.
Scott, how mportant is space in the picture,
when you think about the problems we have
here on the ground.
So I, uh, you know, for one, it's a technology
accelerator. I don't, I don't, you know, I'm
not a believer that if it wasn't for Apollo,
we wouldn't have cell phones right now or
that we wouldn't have computers. But I think-
Well space food sticks and Tang for sure.
We've got that.
And we do have the space ice cream, which
we actually don't have in space believe it
or not, but uh, yeah. So I, I think, you know,
doing the hardest thing we can do, uh, requires
us to develop technologies to do that. And
I think that improves our lives here on earth.
Um, I also agree that we are explorers and
as soon as uh, stop, uh, exploring and we
look inward, we're probably not going to exist
for very much longer. I think that is part
of our DNA, uh, to always want to see what
is a over the horizon, whether that's the
horizon of, uh, of the ocean or the horizon
of the moon or eventually Mars.
But if you made the argument that everything
I just said was wrong and the only thing we
got out of space flight is that kids in this
country or around the world were motivated
to become scientists and engineers to do their
homework, to work in fields that are incredibly
important to our economy. Incredibly important
to our national security. If the investment
alone just got us motivated and moving in
a positive direction towards developing scientists
and engineers I think every penny is well
worth the expense. And the last thing is,
I spent over 500 days on the International
Space Station. There was no money there. All
that money was spent on earth, you know, with
people and with high paying jobs, good jobs,
people that then, you know, go on to pay their
taxes to send their kids to college. So I
think it's an investment in our future in,
you know, many, many different ways.
Leland, what'd you go along with that?
I agree with Scott and I just think that this,
this wiring of us in our DNA to explore it
is one of the biggest things that we do with
space, whether it's the oceans or space. And
when I was interviewed to become an astronaut,
there were 2,500 people that applied. I was
one of 25 us astronauts chosen. And right
before I was chosen, John Young turned to
me and he said, Leland, if we stop exploring,
we will falter as a civilization. And so I
believe John Young and I know that if we stop
doing this, we're going to die as a civilization.
The other thing is, you know Scott, you just
said, I had a chance to talk to a kid when
he was 16 years old at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory wearing this blue flight suit,
and I gave a commencement speech at George
Mason and this young guy walks up to me and
he says, hey, do you remember me? I'm getting
my PhD in aerospace engineering because you
told me that I could.
That's one kid. So, if we can do this, maybe
that kid is not going to fly in space, maybe
they’re going to cure cancer or maybe they're
going to get in some other field in build
your rockets or something. But this hope,
this inspiration, this leadership is something
that I think we have to do. Whether wherever
the exploration goes, we must explore.
Should we go back to the moon? Shall we press
toward Mars? How much does that matter if
it's about inspiring young people? Is it at,
will any mission do?
I think, uh, I think going to Mars is showing,
I mean, what President Kennedy said back in
the day, it's because we do the things that
are hard and we've been to the moon. We've
demonstrated that. Do we need to have a lunar
base as a, as a launch pad to get us to Mars?
I don't think so, but if we decide to do this
as a civilization, as a people, let's put
the money up there and do it and go do it
just like Kennedy did.
What do you think, moon?
Well there, I think there are probably some
teenagers in here and I don't know if you
guys are aware of this.
Stand up, teenagers.
All teenagers stand, yeah! The Mars generation!
We're glad you're here tonight.
I don't know if you realize this, but you
guys have never been on the earth with all
of the people. Your whole lives, there has
always been people in space and I think one
of the things we should make a commitment
to is never changing that. I think no matter
what we do, and someday we will have to put
the a International Space Station or at least
parts of it in the, in the Pacific Ocean,
I think we should make a commitment to always
having people in space and at least that keeps
us moving in the positive, in a positive direction.
You know, someday we're going to go to Mars.
I hope I get to see it. I hope you guys get
to do it. Uh, maybe we should go back to the
moon. I think that's a choice depending on
really about how much money you have to invest.
But I think the planet needs to make a commitment
to always have people in space. We got a 20
year record. Don't want to break it.
All right. So I'm just going to go down the
panel, starting with Ariane. Paint the vision,
50 years from now when we come back and do
this event again and we'll all be here. What
will we be, where will we be in space? You
think? What's your prediction?
Uh, I mean I think that um, I think that there
are going to be a lot more people in space.
I think that's going to be driven by the improvements
in uh, reusable rockets that are going to
be able to get people and again, you know,
space stations or other sorts of heavy infrastructure
up there. Um, and I think it's going to, as
we're seeing here, uh, touch a lot more people's
lives, um, through various elements of space
technology, whether it's people actually getting
up into space or them being able to benefit
from the technology that's coming from space.
Will there be millions by 50 years or thousands
or hundreds?
I don't think necessarily millions. That vision
of millions of people living and working in
space, you know, is it my grandchildren? Is
it your grandchildren or their grandchildren?
We'll see. We'll see. And in fact, I think
frankly, the future is, is to be written by
them, right? So we can predict all day, but
it's the young people in the audience and
the future generations that are gonna make,
that are gonna paint the picture.
All right, Leland, 50 years from now.
50 years from now, I'm inspired. These students
who stood up, these kids who stood up, a lot
of these kids don't see race and don't see
color and don't see isms. So I am very hopeful
that in 50 years some of those kids will be
orbiting Mars, working together as close knit
teams with their friends and family and people
from all around the planet. Um, I think it's
possible if we as a society decide that this
is important. And you know, my experience
on the space station working with people from
around the world, it, it changed me and I
think they're already changed in the things
that they do and the tweeting and texting
and IG-ing and all of this connectivity even
though sometimes a little too much, but um,
but they will make it there, and we'll be
on Mars whether it's on the planet or orbiting
it's Mars.
Scott.
Well, I agree mostly with what my two colleagues
here just said. And if you consider the fact
that we went from flying an airplane for the
first time in 1903 and then, um, general Collins
here and Neil and Buzz, uh, stepped foot on
the moon on Apollo 11, uh, what was that 66
years later. I mean, if you think about that,
you know, advancement in technology and just
barely over 50 years, what our potential is.
Now, whether we, you know, use that potential
to create a space industry that is vibrant,
that have, have a, a lot of people, uh, having
access to space, to going back to the moon
and Mars. I don't know, you know, if you consider
the fact that there are going to be people
in the U S air force flying the B52, that's
going to be a hundred years old at one point.
People will be flying a hundred year old airplane
in the US Air Force. Nothing against the B52,
but I mean, you can see how you can sometimes
just kind of get stuck and keep doing the
same thing. And I hope we don't wind up there.
Mike we'll end it with you. I want to modify
the question. You have a two part. You have
a bonus question in addition to a, the question
I've asked everybody else I want to add, have
you first answer, if I asked you this same
question 50 years ago, what would you have
said?
No, I don't want to answer that one. I want
to, uh, I want to say what 50 years from now
will bring.
Well go ahead and, uh, you get to do what
you want.
And, and I, I don't know, I haven't a clue,
but I think you will figure it out. I think
the young people today are smarter. There's
you guys, or men and women, black, white,
whatever. You're smarter than I am. You'll
figure it out. You have, you're working from
a, a bigger database. Part of that thanks
to the space program. Most of it not, but
you'll, you'll, you'll work it out. I'm very
optimistic. Uh, that, uh, your, your future
that you will chart as time goes by, is better
than the future that I would perhaps predict
right now.
Good place to end it. Mike Collins, Scott
Kelly, Leland Melvin, Ariane Cornell. Give
it up for them, give it up. Thank you so much,
great conversation.